this episode is made possible by the
realistic online game war thunder check
out this game through the link in the
description below go through that link
and you'll not only support this show
which is nice of you but you'll also get
a free premium tank or aircrafts in
three days of premium time as a bonus
for registering and let's get into it
[Music]
Nikita Khrushchev's name is still enough
to conjure images of flying missiles and
nuclear devastation the Soviet premier
who succeeded Stalin Khrushchev was a
Russian bear of a man an ogre who banged
his shoe on a podium at the United
Nations and told Americans we will bury
you his rule in the 1950s and the 1960s
coincided with the height of the Red
Scare in the US and for a generation
he was the West's ultimate bogeyman he
was indeed the man who engineered the
Cuban Missile Crisis that nearly ended
the world but there is much more to
Khrushchev than Cuba and nuclear war the
first peasant leader of the USSR he was
a zealous reformer who tore down the
bloody edifice of Stalinism under
Khrushchev's watch prisoners were freed
communism was liberalized and life was
improved for millions of people yet he
threw all of this away with
international theatrics that ultimately
led to a Soviet coup
so was he the bad guy of the 20th
century or was he just a misunderstood
reformer well today we are diving into
the life of the USSR's most
controversial premier
although he would publicly identify with
the Ukraine for most of his life nikita
khrushchev was actually born in
kalinovka in Russia on April the 17th
1894 Khrushchev's family were the exact
sort of people the Communists idealized
his father was a coal miner in his
grandfather had been a serf who served
in the Tsar's arni the only discordant
note in this otherwise perfect
proletarian upbringing was the heavy
presence of religion not the Khrushchev
would have any problems ditching
Christianity later in life when he was
just the lad Khrushchev's parents moved
across the border two years after in
Ukraine which is now Donetsk it was in
years of cos grim industrial wastelands
that Khrushchev finally found his
calling he got a job as a pipe fitter
aged 15 before becoming a skilled
metalworker in his teenage heart dream
it began to bloom a dream of becoming an
engineer and a man of standing in
russian imperial society even married an
educated woman who encouraged his
ambition with this modest dream it was
now to be swept away by a tsunami On
June the 28th 1914 a Serbian terrorist
assassinated Austrian Archduke Franz
Ferdinand in Sarajevo barely a month
later the whole of the Russian Empire
was marching to war to protect Serbia
from Austrian retaliation and that's as
he might know marked the beginning of
World War one but while Khrushchev vital
factory work kept him from enlisting in
the Tsar's army he wouldn't be able to
avoid what came next on March the 8th
1917 frustration at nearly three years
of badly run warfare it exploded across
Russia the February revolution so-called
because the Russian Empire still used
the old Julian calendar toppled the Tsar
and placed the Empire in the hands of
the provisional government in Ukraine
people they went nuts the Tsar's hated
regime was gone and ordinary people they
were in charge riding this heavy wave of
optimism Khrushchev signed up with a new
Bolshevik Party it was just in time on
November the 7th 1917 Vladimir Lenin
engineered the October Revolution the
Bolsheviks stormed the winter palace in
Petrograd overthrew the provisional
government and declared a Socialist
Republic this was one of the biggest
single events of the 20th century bands
in immediate consequences in Ukraine
war erupted pissing the red forces of
Bolshevism against the white forces of
the Tsar it was complicated further by
uprisings of Ukrainian nationalists and
later and invasion by the polish army
determined to protect his adopted
Republic Khrushchev enlisted in the Red
Army in 1919 and he was sent to the
Polish border for the next three years
he fought the poles and the pro royalist
whites until on October 25th 1922 the
Red Army finally declared victory that
December the USSR it was officially
created back in what was now the
Ukrainian Soviet Socialist Republic
Khrushchev that he'd immobilized but
there was no time for celebration just
as the war ended
Khrushchev's first wife she died some
sources say it was from famine brought
about by the conflicts others say that
she contracted typhus left with two
children to raise the now a dog
Khrushchev he returned two years of care
and enrolled in the Soviet workers
school determined to complete his
education much later it would be said
that this more than the army is where
Khrushchev discovered his loyalty to the
new regime under the Tsar a poor peasant
from the Ukraine Russia border would
have no chance of getting even a high
school education now the Communists were
in power Khrushchev was suddenly able to
access a world of knowledge once
reserved for Russia's elite perhaps
that's why not long after he enrolls
Khrushchev he took a major step one
which would affect both his life and the
lives of everyone in the USSR he became
the leader of the Azov cos student
Communist Party
[Music]
Khrushchev's rise up the Soviet system
it wasn't dramatic rather than shoot to
the top the former peasants he rose
slowly but surely it started with a
promotion to the leader of the Azov
Korean Communist Party then there was
reassignment to the biggest city of
Kharkov then from there it was to a
position at the top of the kiev party
for a man who'd been a pipe cleaner just
a decade before lording it over
metropolitan Kiev should have been
enough that Khrushchev he wanted more
than Ukraine was able to give him in
1929 he went to Moscow provisionally to
study metallurgy in reality it was to
build a power base in no time at all
Khrushchev was put in charge of
constructing the Moscow subway an
incredibly important assignment he
carried out his duties so well that the
party made him the Communist equivalent
of the governor of Moscow by 1936
Khrushchev he was an influential rising
star with a strong power base in both
Moscow and the Ukraine it's a
description that should have seen him as
one of the first to die in the Great
Purge lasting from 1936 to 1938 the
Great Purge was Stalin's unhinged
killing spree against anyone with a
power base to rival his own if you've
seen our video on NKVD head of entry
barrier you know that even ultra
loyalists like barrier nearly died in
Stalin's witch-hunts by rights Krishna
story it should sort of end here with
him being shot in the back in some
anonymous Moscow courtyard on a chilly
night as Chris Jeff had a quality that
no one else in the party had during the
Great Purge a quality that would save
his life and that quality he was
ridiculous yeah far from being respected
Khrushchev he's regarded there's a total
joke he was barely 5 foot 2 inches tall
and he looks like something Ukrainian
village idiot he drank like a fish and
Stalin would sometimes make him do funny
dances to entertain on the party leaders
it was this amazing combination while
the vast majority of powerful communists
were out being murdered Khrushchev was
loudly supporting Stalin in public and
acting as the tyrants jester in private
as a result Khrushchev not only survived
the great purge but he benefited from it
in 1938 he was made a member of the
police abuse and elevated to the
position of leader of Ukraine back in
his old stomping ground Khrushchev kept
cultivating his image of a star
loyalists on the old Ben's orders he
oversaw the bloody Soviet invasion of
eastern Poland before organizing
resistance to Hitler's 1941 invasion of
the USSR to call the next few years
bloody would do a massive disservice to
blood from 1941 to 1944 the Nazis
occupied Ukraine killing around 7
million people when Khrushchev regains
control he conducted his own purge of
German aligned Ukrainians
this was then followed in 1946 by a
famine that killed another million
people it is this last catastrophe that
started Chris Jeff's slow drift from
Stalinism the famine was exacerbated by
Soviet collective farming and grain
quotas something which appalled
Khrushchev who you have to remember he
loved Ukraine like it was his homeland
not that his disillusionment would come
into the open just quite yet in 1949
Khrushchev was recalled to Moscow by
Stalin as part of the old man's plan to
balance Paris in a circle a long silent
of entry barrier Deputy Prime Minister
Nikolai Bulganin and second party
secretary Gorion Malenkov Khrushchev
became a fixture at Stalin's dacha where
once again the tyrants made the little
Ukrainian dances funny little dance for
Khrushchev the next few years they were
miserable away from his power base in
Ukraine day in the part of court
gestures Stalin he lives a life of
low-grade humiliation but something was
about to happen that would shake up not
just the lives of Khrushchev barrier
bullion in Mallen Cove but the lives of
the entire Communist world and that's
because now it's time to discuss the
death of Stalin
[Music]
on March the 1st 1953 a servant entered
Stalin's bedroom to find the dictator
lying unconscious in a pool of his own
urine the Man of Steel had suffered a
stroke although he would cling on for a
few more days it was the beginning of
the end for Stalinism it was also the
beginning of the beginning for Chris
Jeff's rise to power at the moment of
Stalin's death the path to succession
well it was muddier than the actual mud
in terms of position Georgi Malenkov had
the best claim to the throne but the
wily barrier had the power base to
propel himself to clear front-runner
Khrushchev he was the second or maybe
even a third tier choice even Molotov
who'd recently been on Starlin skill
list was seen as more influential power
Baraka British chef he was also a man
who was often underestimated and that
allowed him to move against the others
before they realized what was happening
within nine days of Stalin's death Malan
cough had been sidelined Baria assumed
this mented won and started enacting his
own liberalizing reforms but in the
shadows Khrushchev watched just biding
his time when barriers reforms triggered
of workers revolt in East Germany he
pounced on June the 26 1953 Khrushchev
denounced barrier in a closed meeting
Malan garv by now on Khrushchev side
called in the Red Army soldiers and
barrier was shot dead in the aftermath
Khrushchev
secured the post of first Secretary of
the Communist Party with Malan cough
having the position of premier that it
was clear who was really in charge
Khrushchev's rule it started slowly he's
met his first year's sidelining Malenkov
patching things up with Stalin's old
enemy Tito and Yugoslavia and
transferring Crimea to the Ukraine
something that would later cause
problems as you're probably aware then
on February the 25th 1956 Khrushchev
abruptly changed gear the change it was
a speech delivered before the 20th Party
Congress it's known today as the secret
speech because it was only ever meant to
be heard by party officials but the
reality was that someone had leaked it
to the New York Times walking in at 6
hours
the speech demolished Stalin's
personality cults it criticized the dead
leader for killing innocent communists
during the great purge and quoted a long
suppressed letter written by Lenin
advising that Stalin never be given
power to modern ears Khrushchev speech
actually seems pretty weak the only
aspect of Stalin's rule that are
attacked the bits that directly affected
law party members like Khrushchev not
the campaign's of terror and the
starvation that killed millions at the
time though it was a shocking as if
Khrushchev had thrown a live grenade
from the podium for two decades the
party had been brainwashed into thinking
that Stalin was the greatest world
leader ever and now the big man's
successor was telling them that starrin
was a tyrant the speech it triggered
something called the Khrushchev thought
over the next few years millions of
political prisoners they were released
and censorship was relaxed this was the
start of a new era for the USSR although
this brave new world would still be
repressive it would be a utopia compared
to how things were under Stalin there
were some exceptions the news of the
speech triggered a revolution in
communist Hungary which crew should have
crushed as brutally as Stalin would've
on the other hands when the speech also
triggered an uprising in Poland
Khrushchev flew to Warsaw and signed a
deal giving the independent communist
republics of Eastern Europe previously
unheard of autonomy whether the party
liked it or not things they were
changing Fenella Goffe and mothers of
tho the feeling was very much not in
June of 1957 they organized a coup to
topple Khrushchev and return a Stalinist
system and it nearly worked a vote in
the politico
actually passed to depose Khrushchev and
it was only getting the hero of the Red
Army marshal Zhukov on side that saved
Khrushchev but survived he did expelling
Malenkov and Molotov and even having his
allies Zhukov removed from power by
March of 1958 there was no energy left
in the Stalinists Khrushchev became the
undisputed leader of the USSR now here
is the only game in town now just before
we get into the USSR and to Khrushchev I
do want to thank today's sponsor war
thunder
it sponsors like war Thunder help us
make these super long videos switch with
a topic like this which is often
demonetised
is you know it's helpful so if you want
all the fun of battle without you know
the real death and horror that you're
hearing about in today's video you
should absolutely check out war thunder
it's a realistic free-to-play military
vehicle combat game war thunder is
available on PC ps4 Xbox one so if you
got any of those devices you're covered
but you only need one all you need to do
is just download and play the game it's
free no need to purchase and in this
game there are over 1200 historically
accurate vehicles all the way from the
1920s to the 1990s so really covering
that time period you heard about in
today's video they're all carefully
built and incredibly detailed and all
the physics has been really sweated over
so that's all very very good sound is
great as well just go watch a trailer or
maybe we'll play a bit of it now so you
can get a feel for that
you
hello you can just jump in play a quick
arcade game which is used for you don't
have much time or you can play realistic
mode for a more challenging tactical
scenario or if you're hardcore I'm not
I haven't played simulator it's
apparently very very difficult I don't
like getting my ass whipped over and
over again but if you're really up for a
challenge try that mode so join us on
the battlefield for free using the link
below doing that like I said supports
this show it gets you a free premium
tank or aircraft and three days of
premium time as a bonus just for
registering and let's get back to our
story of the USSR and how it does to the
new leader shall we
you
the next few years were a dizzying time
via average Soviet citizen if you
imagine the USSR as a battered old car
that's been puttering along under Stalin
Khrushchev's rule was like watching a
drunken madman grab the wheel and go
veering off on a demented and possibly
dangerous new course for the first time
honest-to-god consumer products they
appeared on shelves in bookstores
subversive literature it was suddenly
available
the shocking gulag Chronicle one day in
the life of Ivan Denisovich was
published with Khrushchev's personal
blessing in the cities a wave of new
apartment blocks gave people something
resembling their own personal space for
the first time in years
foreign travel it was suddenly opened
within the party dozens were held
accountable for their role in the purges
although Khrushchev conveniently forgot
about his own involvement in 1961
Khrushchev even had Stalin's body
removed from Lenin's Mausoleum on Red
Square that same year
Stalingrad it was renamed Volga grat it
wasn't all sunshine and rainbows of
course there was still a secret police
there were still do lags there was still
repression this was the USSR after all
the difference was that repression and
decreased Jeff was harassment and
intimidation and paying endless bribes
whereas in Stalin's time assembly meant
that the secret police was shooting
millions of people not that all of Chris
Jeff's reforms went well though in 1956
Khrushchev authorized the opening of
millions of acres of virgin land in
Siberia and Kazakhstan to farming in an
attempt to end the sort of famines that
had witnessed in Ukraine this went about
as well as you'd expect when you send
untrained people to go and farm in
Siberia it's pretty cold though most of
the world though Khrushchev he was a
breath of fresh air he talked about
living in peaceful coexistence with the
West and a sign from that time he sold
American reporters we will bury you he
actually seemed to mean it in 1959 the
USSR in the United States even hosted
joint Expos in their countries showing
off Soviet living to the Americans and
vice versa on July the 24th Khrushchev
went to all the American expo in Moscow
where he bumped into none other than
Richard Nixon he stood before a model of
an American kitchen and the two engaged
in something known as the kitchen debate
it was a semi light-hearted Wang
measuring contest between the two
nations and the debates or Khrushchev
and Nixon both argue why their system of
government
with besa what I can say from the way
you talk and the way you dominate the
conversation you would have made a good
lawyer you're saying
Marcus chefs notorious temper could have
turned it into a diplomatic incident it
instead became a symbol for how the US
and the Soviet Union might be able to
agree to disagree
that same year with relations seemingly
warming Khrushchev left the USSR and
embarked on a tour of the USA for those
who grew up associating Chris chefs name
with the words Missile Crisis the image
of the Russian bear in Iowa munching on
hot dogs and chatting with thanks and
Nitra can seem almost comically strange
yet
history is sometimes pretty strange
Khrushchev's tour of America the first
by a Soviet leader it was a media
sensation
although anti nuclear talks with
Eisenhower went nowhere the trip was
mostly deemed a PR success as 1960
dawned it even began to seem as if the
two supervised they weren't destined to
annihilate one another it seems that
there might be room in the world for
communism and capitalism to coexist if
anyone really did think that the world
they were about to get a fairly rude
awakening
on October the 4th 1957 the USSR Sputnik
1 blasted off from the plains of
Kazakhstan becoming the first man-made
satellite in orbit not four years later
on April the 12th 1961 Soviet rocket
carried another first into orbit this
time it was a man named Yuri Gagarin on
that day he became the first ever human
to experience spaceflight for Soviet
citizens these two phenomenal
achievements were just yet more good
news from the Khrushchev Thor
over in the Pentagon though the American
position it was one of worry it wasn't
just because the Soviets for making NASA
looked like Hicks but also because those
Rockets were capable of delivering
something much more serious than
cosmonauts that was of course nuclear
weapons these fears crystallized on
October the 14th 1962 Valente an
American spy plane passing over Cuba
snapped a rather strange picture the
previous couple of years had been rather
strained between the United States and
its Island neighbor in 1959 Fidel Castro
had come to power on the back of a
communist revolution not two years later
the new JFK administration had tried to
invade the island and toppled Castro
resulting in an enormous scrub that
you've probably heard of called the Bay
of Pigs on top of that our relations had
gone rather south with the USSR
Khrushchev had reacted angrily to the
Bay of Pigs and there was this image of
him banging his shoe on a table at the
UN in 1960 that convinced the Americans
that he was a bit unstable as the spy
plane pilot snapped his pictures and
flew away from that warm Caribbean day
he had no way of knowing that his images
would soon lead the planet to the brink
of nuclear war the pictures showed a
Soviet nuclear launch pad being
constructed in Cuba apocalyptic missiles
were now stationed just 90 miles from
the US mainland when the news reached
Washington the world
it entered crisis mode Khrushchev's
whole rationale was that the US had
installed its own missiles in Turkey
even closer to the USSR than the Cuban
missiles were to America
surely the Americans would just have to
learn to deal with it at the thought of
an atomic bomb exploding over Miami or
Houston it forced Americans to hit back
on the 22nd of October JFK gave a
televised address informing the world
about the missiles he pledged to set up
a naval blockade to stop more missiles
reach in Cuba and gave the USSR an
ultimatum remove
missiles in Cuba or its war in the
Kremlin Khrushchev he tried to hold his
nerve the USSR was already failing at
the nuclear arms race if it lost its new
outpost in Cuba who knew what would
happen and thus began the highest stakes
game of chicken in history on October
the 24th Soviet ships carrying
additional missiles reached the US naval
blockade the two sides were one mistake
from nuclear war three days later a u.s.
pilot was shot down over Cuba with
tensions now at breaking bones people
across the planet began to prepare for
the ends at any moments the human race
could be snuffed out in a flash of
atomic light the fact that it wasn't is
simply due to two pieces of paper on
October the 28th 1962 Khrushchev cracked
he sent JFK to Argent notes the first
said the Cuban nuclear facilities would
be dismantled if the u.s. swore to never
launch another invasion of Cuba the
second demanded that the u.s. nuclear
missiles also be removed from Turkey
although the Kennedy administration only
publicly agreed to the first note they
secretly let Moscow know that there
abide by the second as well and just
like that the world snapped back from
the abyss so what was going through
Khrushchev was in mind as he sent those
notes the American version has it that
the crisis was simply a high-stakes
poker game and the USSR blinked thirst
but maybe there was something more here
for all of his faults Khrushchev wasn't
a psychopath he didn't want to destroy
the world
it was certainly his fault that the
missiles were in Cuba in the first place
but maybe he also deserves credit for
not seeing his dangerous Bluff through
regardless the crisis ended without the
planet burning the Soviets retreated and
the Americans they kept their promises
the next year a hotline was installed
between the White House and the Kremlin
to prevent future apocalypses in his
later memoirs Khrushchev would lead to
call the resolution to the crisis a
personal triumph bus they were very few
in Moscow who saw it that way from the
moment that a US spy plane first took
that photo over Cuba Khrushchev as days
in the Kremlin they were numbered
the ripple effects of the Cuban Missile
Crisis were felt across the globe in
Asia they became the final nail in the
coffin for the relationship between the
USSR and China the sino-soviet split had
begun way back with Khrushchev secret
speech but it was the bungled missile
crisis that convinced Mao to break with
Moscow fingers he actually even called
Khrushchev a buffoon in the structures
of the Communist Party the perceived
humiliation of Khrushchev climbed down
made people question the leader in ways
that they hadn't since malankov's failed
coup perhaps all these reforms that gone
to Khrushchev said perhaps what the USSR
needed was less liberalism and more
Orthodoxy I mean they didn't want to go
all the way back to Stalinism but you
know maybe something just slightly less
open and less tolerant and so leonid
brezhnev a protege of Khrushchev and the
fellow Ukrainian although in resonance
case had actually been born there
Brezhnev was also a deeply ambitious man
although Khrushchev was clearly grooming
him to be a successor Regin if you
didn't want to wait and now with the
tide of opinion finally turning against
Khrushchev the pupil he could turn on as
master on October the 14th 1964
Khrushchev was on vacation in Georgia
when reg Neve launched his coup while
every previous Soviet handover of power
had been accompanied by bloodshed this
time things were almost totally reg
enough took control of the party ordered
Khrushchev back to Moscow and made him
resign as a leader wisely Khrushchev he
accepted this early retirement and that
was it for Khrushchev the man who D
Stalin i's dan empire he was allowed to
live but he was shunted off into
anonymity
Khrushchev he was forbidden from
speaking out the press were encouraged
not to report on him and his name was
quietly scrubbed from Soviet life
although Brezhnev didn't kill his old
mentor how he felt about him is evidence
from what happens when Khrushchev
finally died on September the 11th 1971
while his passing made headlines in the
West the Soviet press they didn't
mention it for 48 hours before finally
putting out a small notice there was no
state funeral there was no burial and
the Kremlin wall less than a decade
after he'd left office it seemed
Khrushchev had already been forgotten
the Khrushchev he wasn't done yet over a
decade after his death a group of
younger communists they came to power
known as the children of the 20th Party
Congress they were the generation of
party members who watched enraptured as
Khrushchev
heed a secret speech one of them that
was Mikhail Gorbachev in the late 1980s
Gorbachev would implement his own
version of Khrushchev's reforms known as
glass nor stand perestroika that
eventually lead to the ussr's
dissolution
nor was Gorbachev the only communist
leader that Khrushchev influenced the
Khrushchev thought had been credited
with inspiring everything from the
Prague Spring in 1968 - dang shoppings
opening of the Chinese markets in the
1980s almost every liberalizing strain
of communism it can be traced back to
the secret speech so at the end of all
of that
what's the historical verdict on
Khrushchev as we said at the start for
many in the West it's the Missile Crisis
certainly that was a huge part of his
Premiership there was more than that
Khrushchev was the first Soviet premier
to stop the mass killings to end the
daily terror of life under Stalin sure
that society he led was still awfully
repressive but it was an improvement by
orders of magnitude from the one that
had come before him in another timeline
without Khrushchev you'd have one of the
Stalinist season controlled in 1953 and
you'd have many more decades of
unbridled mass murder you'd never have
the thought you'd never have D Stalin
ization Khrushchev he may have had his
faults but in many ways he was also the
right man at the right time history may
judge him harshly for his mistakes but
it shouldn't forget his successes so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below also don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
we put out new videos several times a
week so doing that while notifying you
about those also why not check out my
other channel called top tens you'll
find a link to that below and as always
thank you for watching